les appartements avec des grands balcons
en rez de jardin qui habituellement est
aidé bien qu'on avait notamment les rez
de jardin qu'on avait du mal à vendre
c'est devenu un petit peu aujourd'hui
les biens qui sont les plus recherchées
dans la ville de chatou et ses alentours
les prix du marché immobilier s'envole
dans cette agence immobilière la
directrice constate une augmentation des
prix au mètre carré jusqu'à 9000 euros
pour les biens d'exception c'est par
quartier hier le quartier proche à
robert d'ailleurs maximum 15 minutes et
encore 15 minutes ce sont les quartiers
les plus recherchés par contre dès qu'on
s'éloigne et qu'on va donc on a permis
au lait ou de chatou
c'est beaucoup moins demande et les prix
sont moins en moins envolée en cause
bien sûr la crise sanitaire qui a poussé
de nombreux franciliens à venir
s'installer ici en s'éloignant du centre
de paris tout en profitant d'un cadre de
vie plus élevée l'attractivité de chatou
le rer a les biens sont donc désormais
rares aujourd'hui on a une pénurie de
biens meilleurs qu'on a beaucoup
d'acquéreurs on les voit un réveil
samedi ils font les agences autour qui
ont des très gros budget est par contre
on n'a pas les biens forcément face qui
recherchent pas ce que parce que le
marché n'est pas le même qu'à paris dans
cet autre agence immobilière à chatou
même constat tous les biens se vendent
très rapidement on est à flux tendu
c'est à dire qu'on rentre un bien
quoique même si c'est une petite
toute petite surface sa part et jusqu'à
les demandes six ans un million de 1
million à 2 millions sa part et tout par
son négociations et le types
d'acquéreurs a désormais changé on a
beaucoup de jeunes couples qui arrive
effectivement principalement de paris le
neuilly levallois et ils savent très
bien qu'en titans un appartement un bel
appartement
ils vont ici avoir une très belle maison
à chatou les prix moyens des maisons ont
augmenté de 18 % en cinq ans est
d'environ 6% seulement pour l'année 2020